For thousands of years, Fulani boys like 16-year-old Yoro Sisse have made a dangerous journey.
They leave their girlfriends and families behind in Diafarabe, Mali,...
...and walk across the edge of the Sahara Desert.
They make this dangerous journey for one reason: to feed their cattle.
At the end of the dry season,...
...the boys must take their cattle out of the Inner Niger Delta and into the Sahel.
Soon, it will be too wet in the delta and the herdsmen must travel to find better grazing areas.
The Sahel is an arid region with very few plants and trees.
It follows the edge of the Sahara Desert.
Cattle like a temperate climate.
The success of the Fulani people is a direct result of their ability to raise cattle in this arid environment.
These young cattle herdsmen live away from home for up to eight months a year.
While they're away, they live mainly on milk from their dairy cows.
We constantly have to find new grazing.
That's what's always in your mind.
In the bush, we have to be completely focused.
Our mission is to bring back fat cattle.
Bringing home a healthy herd is a traditional rite of passage for Fulani boys.
If a Fulani boy returns with healthy cattle, then he is considered to be a man.
When Yoro returns, the other Fulani people will look carefully at the cattle,...
...then they'll decide if he's capable of managing a herd properly.
Yoro's girlfriend, Aissa, hopes that he's done well.
She has a good reason for doing so: she's now old enough to get married.
Fulani parents choose who their daughters and sons marry.
If Yoro doesn't bring his herd home in excellent condition,...
...Aissa's parents probably won't choose him to be her husband.
During the journey, Yoro has to make sure that his cattle get enough food, but that's not his only worry.
There are rebels, cattle rustlers and dangerous mosquitoes that can cause serious diseases.
Yoro starts his journey in Diafarabe, Mali, and walks into Mauritania.
He follows routes that may have existed for thousands of years.
They've been here since a time when people and cattle were first forced into the Sahel.
As the Sahara region dried out,...
...the people that lived there had to leave and find a more temperate climate.